[MUSIC]
The most important thing there is to know
your partner.
You really be,
need to be confident and business strategy
of those with whom you're investing.
It's very difficult to invest all alone in
China so,
very important to have a reliable partner.
Part of that is relationship with the
central government of China, and
the local governments, and part of it is,
trust.
It's difficult to work out disagreements
in China's courts.
So you really need to trust with whom
you're working in.
Be confident that their business plan is a
good shot.
Of course there's risk everywhere.
But I think those are the keys that we've
been told about.
[MUSIC]
Well first of all, capital markets are to
a large extent, closed.
You can't simply inject capital into
China's economy right now without
permission from the government.
So, that's the first hurdle that you need
to get over
is to get permission to invest.
And then once you're, you get through that
you know,
their, the, the key concerns are the ones
that I mentioned earlier,
investing with a trusted partner and a
business plan that makes a lot of sense.
Of course having a business plan that
doesn't run counter to
the interests of the government is very
important in China,
because it's not a completely open free
market like it is in the United States.
The Chinese use the expression state
directed capitalism,
which means that the state does play a
significant role in the economy.
And if you should run cross-purposes with
the intentions of
the government, you may find yourself in
difficulty.
[MUSIC]
I'll give you one example.
In the United States when when a firm
borrows money in debt capital markets,
investors are very aware that if the firm
is risky that either you
don't lend it money or if you do you lend
it at a very high interest rate.
And the result of that is that capital
gets allocated to the firms with the best
business plans.
In China that hasn't been working so well.
For two reasons.
Number one for, for what ever reason
default is considered
an extremely adverse result in China
relative to the U.S.
and when a corporation gets into trouble
either it's local government, or
the central government is very prone to
bail it out.
Which means that if I'm an investor in
corporate bonds, I don't really care all
that much about which bonds I invest in,
most of them are gonna pay off anyway and
that means that companies with the best
business plans have not a very big, big
advantage relative to companies that don't
really have a good business plan at all.
The second reason I'm interested in it is
that China has a,
only a very nascent bond market.
In the United States,
roughly two-thirds of corporate credit is
provided through securities markets.
In China, it's just a tiny, tiny fraction.
Shockingly, China has as much corporate
debt as the United States, but
only a tiny, tiny fraction of it is
obtained through bond work and it,
that means that it's not gonna be possible
for China to continue to grow at the rate
it has been or anything close unless it
develops a very effective bond market,
because as corporations get larger and
larger, they can't rely only on bank
loans, they need access to bond markets as
well to get cheap enough capital.
[MUSIC]
In China, there are four large banks.
They're kind of analogous to our JP
Morgan,
Citibank, Bank of America Goldman Sachs
and Wells Fargo.
Except at these large,
these four largest banks in China are more
than half owned by the central government.
And if, in order to be a CEO of one of
these four largest banks,
you need to be selected by the Chinese
communist party and
you end up having a sub ministerial or
rank or vice ministerial or
rank in the Chinese government, you're
actually a member of the government.
So that when time comes to decide to whom
you're gonna lend money,
a phone call from a government official
might be very, very influential, and
I think you might have you'd be surprised
if you heard that Jamie Dimon or
Lloyd Blankfein would simply pick up the
phone and make a loan to,
to someone that at the suggestion of
someone in,
in the United States administration, it
doesn't work that way in this country.
So that, that's that's another example of
when you, when you look at the bank,
and you know it has a CEO, it has a board
of directors, it has equity,
it has debt, it operates as a corporation
with public shareholders and yet
it's as much a part of the government as
it is part of financial markets as a,
as a private actor.
[MUSIC]
A former senior partner at Goldman Sachs
was interviewed in by Bloomberg.
And recalled that in 1990 he suggested
that Japan,
which was the rising economic super power
would not
succeed it would, it's growth would stop,
and it would have difficulties,
perhaps financial crisis, and he turned
out to be right.
Now he's saying the same thing about China
and questioning whether
this would be super power will cont, be
able to continue to grow and
will be able to avoid a significant
financial crisis.
He didn't put any hard facts on that,
he said it was a hunch he was very humble
about it, but if you
don't try to look at the facts, examine
the numbers,
understand by talking to people what's
actually going on you would be
significantly influenced by by in those
kinds of suggestions that China is,
is heading for serious difficulty.
I have a, a kind of moderate view on that.
I think China will be able to have a soft
landing at a sustainable growth rate.
Of you know, somewhere between 5 and 7%,
it'll be able to pivot towards its
consumption sector.
Hopefully it'll be able to reduce the
terrible air pollution
that its major cities has, and it'll be
able to open up its capital markets, and
eventually American investors or European
investors will be able to go into China,
just as Chinese investors will be able to
freely invest elsewhere.
That vision has been on everyone's mind
for,
everyone that watches developments in a
the global financial system.
That vision has been on their minds for,
a decade and it, it still seems just over
the horizon.
Will we ever, actually get to that point?
I dont know.
I think that's a big question mark, but
I'm, I'm somewhat optimistic that it's a
question of time.
And a question of, success for
this kind of gradualist policy of trying
one thing after another and hoping that
enough of these things work that that this
sort of progress can be made.
[MUSIC]